κλεισμεηης μας ις αλες χώρες που αναχρονικά διαστήματα αλλάστης ο αριθμός τωμάδο που σημεχνημακακλαμια νέρευναεξεκίνησα
με δώδεκπάμε στεξπάμε στε σε μια πάμε καλήγιατί γίνεται τω καλιερώτηση γιατι γίνε καλήερώτηση το
περίμενα των να μερωτησης επειδή να σοπαντήσω πολύ απλή απαντηση δεν υπάρχει φι εξταρεθμός διότι
η διαφορά μεταξύ της βήτα κατηγορίς με την πρώτην κατηγρία είναι τεράστια οικονομικά ομιλούντας από
την άλη δεν πρέπει να παραγνωρίζουμε ότι τον πάσκαιπέραση και μια περίοδον ας τοπούμε να
τοπο έτσι υπολύ πιο ευγενικά μια μεγάλης οικονομικής ακρίσει κρίσης και βεβαιότιαςσε συνδιασμό και σε
συνάρτηση με την παηλιαςε πουέχέσς που είχαμε των ην ανόαλόγη στην κάθοδον ξένων που στραγκάλησην
οικονομικά τα σωματία υπήρχαν αυτία υπήρχε ν αυτί α βεβαιοτα ο λόγος που που δε
καθορίζεται από την αρχήνα ένα φίστα ριθμός και ναμίνη τώρα δεν ξέρω αν είνες ως
των λάθωεν κάτι οποίο θα ταδούμε εμείς θεωρούμε ότι μεχρη στιγμής βγαίνει το πρωτάθημα μια
χαρά γιατί δίνουμε τη δυνατότη και σε ωμάδε της βειτα κατηγορίας να ανεύουν πάνω αν
μιώθούν οικονομικά δυνατέας ιαένας που τους λόγους που δεν τους πιέζουμε και δεν τους το
επιβάλλουμε είναι ότι δεν θέλουμε να τους πνήξουμε και να φαννα τους να τις αφανίσουμε
από το χάρτη δηλάδή παρατισμα χαρι φέτωση η πρωταθλή τραβήδα κατηγορίας ήταν ια ενάδα γίου
δοεε τη α αν υπόχρειονόταν οι ενάδα γίδοτων εδομετίου να ανέβει στην πρώτην κανηγορία θα
έκανε μια χρονια στην πρώτην κατηγραενδεχωμένος να μη γανενούτε καινίκη όχι όχι δεν θα ξαναπευτει
θα μπενελλου κιτο άρα φήνουμε ν αυτή την αυτή την έση τη δυνατότηταν και να
νάλλον παράδειγμα ή ενοσυνώ παραλημείου πέρση για έκανε μια χρονιά κακί